The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: My first
question is, do you
have any questions about
the last class, about
the introduction, about the
course overview, the syllabus,
any requirements of the
course, formalities?
It should be pretty clear.
So today, we start
from first principles.
I want to give you a
rigorous derivation of what
this course is based,
namely, the Hamiltonian
to describe the interaction
between atoms and light.
I mentioned to you last
week that atomic physics can
be defined about
everything that is
interesting about the building
blocks of nature, atoms
interacting with light
electromagnetic fields, Coulomb
fields, and today, we'll talk
about the first principle,
Hamiltonian.
The reference for
that, and I'm closely
following that derivation,
is the book Atom-Photon
Interaction, the green book
by Cohen-Tannoudji, Grynberg,
and others, and it's
taken from the appendix.
And if you flip
through the appendix,
you will find out that there
are about 100 equations.
Today, we'll discuss
every single of them.
However, the good
news is the result
in the end is simple
and intuitive.
In the end, we
have what we want,
that the electromagnetic
field couples different energy
levels, and then we can play
around with quantum case,
with laser cooling.
All we need is a
coupling matrix element.
And for most of the
course, I will not even
elaborate what this
matrix element is about.
But here, we derive it
from first principles.
The result we will
use most often
is actually the electric
dipole approximation,
which I'm sure you have
already seen many, many times.
So in that sense, I sometimes
have second thoughts.
Should I dedicate
a whole lecture
to derive something
you know already?
On the other hand, this is sort
of the meat of atomic physics,
and I want to go
as deep as possible
into it, that
whenever you wonder
what form of other
interactions exist,
you have a reference
to look it up.
And so to some extent,
I want to also encourage
you to read more about the
fundamental nature of how light
and atoms interact.
I will give you another
reference a little bit
later on.
But as a motivation,
I want to tell you
what I learned when I
prepared this lecture,
and I hope that
there is something
that you will learn
from this treatment.
One is a rigorous
separation of local fields
from radiation fields.
Let me just write it
down, rigorous separation
of local Coulomb fields
from radiation fields.
So to clearly separate the
terms in the Hamiltonian,
let me explain that.
When we introduce
electromagnetic fields
into our world, we would
say we introduce them
by saying particles have charge.
But some parts of the
charged particle physics
is something we want to include
in the description of atoms,
and that's the Coulomb
field of protons.
The structure of atoms
is electromagnetic,
but when we now introduce
electromagnetic field
as a new degree of
freedom-- photons
can be admitted,
absorbed, and such--
we only want to talk about
the electric field which
belongs to the photons and
not the electric field which
belongs to the atoms.
And you may wonder,
can you distinguish
between two kinds
of electric fields?
The answer is yes, and I want to
show you how mathematically you
distinguish when you introduce
electromagnetic fields
between the fields which stay
with the atom, which don't have
an extra degree of
freedom, and if you
do canonical quantization,
they don't enter
as an extra variable, and the
fields which are the photons,
and these are the extra
objects we have to consider.
What is also related is when
you do second quantization,
if you wanted, I could quantize
electromagnetic field for you
in five minutes.
Just say it's
harmonic oscillator.
You're familiar with
harmonic oscillator,
and let's just do it.
Yes, this is correct, and I will
remind you of that a little bit
later, but there is
one non-trivial aspect
if you want to do quantization
of a field theory,
you have to make sure that
before you quantize it,
you know which degrees of
freedom are really independent.
So the question is, how
many independent fields
does the electromagnetic
field have?
The naive answer is three
electric field components,
three magnetic field
components, that makes six.
But of course they're
not independent,
and we will discuss that.
So we'll spend some time
in the identification
of truly independent field
components, or degrees
of freedom of the
electromagnetic field.
So all that is an excursion
into classical physics
because it is just reformulating
classical electrodynamics
to be ready for quantization.
Actually, all the work is
done to discuss and derive
the appropriate
classical description.
That means to eliminate
all redundant variables,
and then at the end, have
variables which, yes,
will look like a
harmonic oscillator.
And once we have reduced it
to degrees of freedom which
look like a harmonic oscillator,
it is very straightforward
to do the field
quantization following
the recipe of the
harmonic oscillator.
There's one more highlight,
if I want to say so,
and this is a truly
rigorous derivation
of the electric
dipole approximation.
In most quantum
mechanics textbooks,
you do a dipole
approximation and you wind up
with the electric dipole
Hamiltonian, which
I have already put up
there, but you do actually
unnecessary
approximations in terms
of neglecting an a squared
term, and there are often
confusing discussions
what happens
with the a squared term.
I want to show you a
more rigorous deviation
of the electric dipole
approximation, which
is including the quadratic term.
That actually means--
that's the take home
message-- the electric dipole
approximation is actually
better than many of you
have thought so far.
Since I don't want to
write out 100 equations,
I copied them and summarized
them out of the book.
You'll find them all,
as I mentioned before,
in the appendix of
Atom-Photon Interaction.
But I sort of want
to walk you through.
What I'm aiming at
is that you have
sort of a complete overview how
is everything coming together,
and if it's just mathematical,
well, mathematics
is always exact.
I can go faster,
but I really want
to highlight here every
single physical concept
and approximation we are doing.
When we start out with
Maxwell's equations,
we have actually six components
of the electromagnetic field,
and we will see in a moment
that this is redundant.
What will turn out to be
very important to separate
the local fields from
the radiation field
is a Fourier transformation,
so we introduce an expansion
into plain waves.
And what then
happens, of course,
is the derivative operator
becomes the k vector.
So therefore, when you
have Maxwell's equations
with the curl, del cross
B, it turns into k cross
B. This is now important because
we have now separate equations
for the component of the
electric and magnetic field,
which is parallel to
k, projected onto k,
and of course, the
cross product takes out
the component which
is perpendicular to k.
So that's something
which is sort of nice,
that the Fourier transform
it allows us to separate
the fields into
longitudinal fields, where
the vector of the
Fourier component
is parallel to the k vector,
and into transverse components.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: The difference
between curly and non-curly
vector is one is a
Fourier transform,
the other one is other
spatial components.
I have to actually
say the book API
tries to be super accurate
in choosing [INAUDIBLE].
Claude Cohen-Tannoudji
is really a master
of elegance and
perfection, so they
don't want to use
the same [INAUDIBLE]
for a spatial component and
for the Fourier component.
On the other hand, I have
to tell you one thing.
For the next hour, use a
little bit your intuition.
If you see e, it
means electric field.
Whether it is curly,
whether it's italic,
whether it's bold
face, don't let
those differences
clutter your view.
So I would say don't
ask me too often,
what exactly does it
mean now because you
have gone from
curly to non-curly?
It is explained in the appendix.
I will tell you everything
which is necessary,
but these are
subtleties which are
more to present the mathematics
in a more rigorous way.
We have the spatial
Fourier components,
and as I mentioned, what you can
do only because of the Fourier
transform, you have
now the distinction,
a rigorous separation
between the parallel
and the longitudinal fields.
So of course, you
can also now get back
what is the longitudinal
field, not in Fourier space
but in position
space, by just taking
the longitudinal or transverse
components of the Fourier
transform and
transforming them back.
Why I'm elaborating
on that is we
will see in the next few minutes
that the transverse field
is the field which propagates.
The longitudinal field
is the Coulomb field.
It belongs to the
atoms and will not
become a new degree of freedom.
And we see that immediately
in the next equations.
When we look now at
Maxwell's equations,
we find that the transverse and
longitudinal fields decouple.
We have two kinds of equations
which are completely decoupled.
The longitudinal electric field
is the Coulomb field associated
with a charge density, whereas
the transverse fields are
creating themselves,
and this is radiation,
how the electric and magnetic
fields create themselves
as they propagate.
Now, the fact that the
parallel electric field
can be expressed by
the charge density,
or it's expressed by the
momentary position of charges,
and this means immediately that
the longitudinal field is not
an independent variable or
an extra degree of freedom.
Canonical, of course,
with how we describe
particles by their position,
and here you see explicitly
that the longitudinal
field which
we defined the way we did it,
that this part of the field
only depends on the momentarily
electric field, the Coulomb
field associated
with the charges.
The next thing, of course,
is to define the vector
potential and the
scalar potential.
By using the standard
substitution,
we can now express electric
and magnetic fields
by a scalar potential and
by a vector potential.
We continue to
have the separation
between longitudinal
and transverse fields,
namely the transverse
electromagnetic fields
depend only on the
transverse component
of the vector potential.
And the transverse component
is gauge invariant.
In other words, you know
there are different gauges we
can consider when we introduce
electromagnetic potentials,
but the choice of gauge does
not affect the transverse vector
potential.
Now we want to pick
our gauge and repeat
the gauge which is
most convenient.
This is typically, for low
energy quantum physics,
for describing atoms and
radiation, the Coulomb gauge.
So we have the freedom of
gauge, and the Coulomb gauge
is written by the divergence
of the vector potential is 0.
If you now think about
Fourier transform,
this means k dot the
Fourier component is 0,
and that means the
vector potential does not
have any longitudinal component.
So with that, we have
now reduced equations
for six variables, three
electric fields, three
magnetic field components.
By introducing vector and scalar
potential, you go to four.
We've eliminated one more
with the Coulomb gauge,
so we have three.
The scalar potential is
the Coulomb potential.
It's not an extra
degree of freedom.
And what is left are
the two field components
of the transverse
vector potential.
And these are now, as we will
see, the independent variables
of the radiation field.
So in other words, when we talk
about the electromagnetic field
in the remainder of
the course, the part
of the electromagnetic
field we are interested in
are the fields generated by the
transverse vector potential.
Now, what is next is to
go into normal modes.
The reason is that
we want to identify
each normal mode of the
electromagnetic field
as an independent
harmonic oscillator.
Now, I'm showing
you those equations,
but you sort of have to sit
back because now there will be
alphas, a's, lower
a's, upper A's.
They all mean pretty
much the same.
In one case, you are
normalized, maybe something
has to be factored out or not.
The derivation in
the appendix of API
is exactly [INAUDIBLE]
distinction,
but let me just give
you a flyover here.
And that is we are now taking
the transverse components
from the electromagnetic field,
and we define new parameters,
which are the normal modes.
What we actually want
to see in a moment
is that those normal
mode variables
are harmonic oscillators.
Those normal modes can be
defined by the original field,
which are transverse,
but since we
have expressed the transverse
field by the transverse vector
potential, they also
simply can be expressed
by the transverse
vector potential.
So to remind you, we've
done a Fourier transform
in the spatial
coordinate, but not
yet in the temporal coordinate.
What we obtain
now is an equation
of motion for the
normal mode variables.
And here, I have reminded you
that the transverse vector
potential, how it can be
expressed by the normal mode
variables.
In other words, yes, it looks
complicated and a little bit
messy, but it's classical
physics, and all we have done
is introduce normal modes in a
just more complicated notation,
as you may have seen it in
803 or some other course
where for the first
time you talked
about normal modes of a
pendulum or a chain of springs.
So we have identified normal
modes by the equation above,
and then it's a
mathematical identity
that our radiation field, our
transverse vector potential,
can simply be expended
into normal modes.
So the equation of motion
for the transverse fields
involves of course, the
transverse vector potential.
I should have scrolled back.
Here we have our equations
for the transverse fields.
This is what we
want to describe,
and if we express everything in
terms of the vector potential,
then we have an equation which
involves the transverse vector
potential, but in addition,
because it's a differential
equation, the first
and second derivative.
That means that if you have
a second order differential
equation, which is
the full description
of the electromagnetic
field, then
you know that the solution
of the second order equation
needs as an initial
condition the field itself
and the first derivative.
Therefore, our
classical fields are
determined by a perpendicular
and its derivative
at the initial time.
So we need a and we need a
dot, and they are coupled,
but what we are
doing right now is--
and this is the idea behind the
normal modes-- the normal modes
coordinates combine a and a dot.
It's the same when you
have a harmonic oscillator
and you want to
introduce coordinates
for the normal mode,
they are a combination
of position and momentum,
and then they are decoupled.
But position and momentum
always couple or oscillate
back and forth, and
the same happens here
between a and a dot, and
the normal mode coordinates
are the linear combination.
In other words, the
equation of motion
coupled source and
normal mode means
that we have introduced
he decoupled normal modes.
And whenever, in classical
physics, we have normal modes,
normal modes means that time
dependence is e to the i omega
t, then we have distilled the
problem of coupled components
to decoupled
harmonic oscillators.
So at this point, each mode
acts as an independent harmonic
oscillator.
So what I wanted to show you
here is clearly, as a flyover,
and as an appetizer to
read more in the book,
that we can start with
the electromagnetic field
components.
We haven't just assumed
we have now empty space
and only [INAUDIBLE] radiation.
We have rigorously separated
the electromagnetic field
in what belongs to the atoms
and what belongs to radiation,
and the trick was a
spatial Fourier component.
At that moment, we
had a description
in terms of the transverse
vector potential,
and by using purely
classical physics,
by combining the vector
potential and its derivative,
we found normal modes,
and they are now
completely independent
harmonic oscillators.
This approach, and I
wanted to show that to you,
involved a lot of notation--
a's, little alphas,
normal modes, and such.
Let me just simply show you
another much, much shorter
pathway how you see that
everything looks and smells
like a harmonic
oscillator, and then we'll
do the last step, which
is rather straightforward.
We quantize the
electromagnetic field.
I could quantize it
right now, but we
should take a short break from
the appendix in Atom-Photon
Interaction and do a
more intuitive shortcut
to the same physics.
Any questions at this point?
If you feel it's
confusing, remind yourself
this is just classical physics.
We are just rewriting Maxwell's
equations in new variables.
So what we do now is,
as I said, let's repeat
some of this deviation
by focusing on energy.
If you write down energy for
our systems of atoms, photons,
and Coulomb fields, we
have particles alpha
with mass m alpha
and velocity v alpha.
This is our kinetic energy.
And then we use the
well known expression
for the electromagnetic
field, which
is the spatial integral over
E squared plus B squared.
This integral over the
electromagnetic field energy
density can actually
be nicely separated
into integral over the
longitudinal field which
we have introduced and
a second integral, which
involves the transverse field.
Of course, the magnetic
field is only transverse
because the divergence of
the magnetic field is 0,
and that means the
magnetic field does not
have any longitudinal component.
So this part here, as
we actually have shown,
is given by simply the
Coulomb energy where
we have charge
density at position r
and r prime interacting with
the Coulomb interaction.
Eventually, if you want
to treat that further,
this Coulomb energy should be
split into some divergent self
energy, which is the energy
of the electron interacting
with itself, and
people know how to deal
with that, and the
interaction energy,
for example, between the
proton and the electron,
which is responsible for
the atomic structure.
So in other words, we know
how to deal with that.
This actually becomes
atomic structure.
This is in contrast
to this part here,
which is the classical energy
of the radiation field, which
is sort of the transverse
part of the energy.
To describe now
radiation, we have
to focus on this
transverse part,
and we are now expressing
the transverse part
by the vector potential
and its derivatives.
So we introduce the vector
potential as before,
and I don't want to go
through the re-derivation.
I just want to show you
how the total energy now
appears in terms of
the vector potential.
And what we need for that
is, of course, the vector
potential and its derivative.
The vector potential
depends on polarization,
depends on the
Fourier component,
and we call this
derivative of the vector
potential the
conjugate momentum.
So now focusing on
energy, we, of course,
reduce everything as before
to the vector potential
and its derivative.
So we sum over polarization.
We integrate over all
Fourier components.
and the integral involves
now the vector potential,
the square of it, or
in complex notation,
the complex conjugate,
depends on polarization.
We have c squared k square.
This part, of course, comes
from the magnetic field,
which depends on the
vector potential.
It's a spatial
derivative, the curl,
and this gives the k
squared, whereas the part
of the electromagnetic
energy, which
is related to the electric
field, the electric field
is a temporal derivative
of the vector potential,
and therefore, it involves
the temporal derivatives which
are now the canonical momenta.
So this equation should
really remind you now--
it's an energy equation-- of the
energy of a harmonic oscillator
because the energy is now
a sum over all oscillators,
but this is sort of x squared,
the amplitude of the oscillator
squared, this is the
potential energy.
And here we have the derivative
of x, the velocity or momentum,
and this should remind
you of the kinetic energy
of a harmonic oscillator.
In other words,
this should tell you
that by focusing on the
transverse component
of the vector potential, it's
about lots of summation-- k
summation,
polarization summation.
We in the end find
that each such mode
is a harmonic oscillator.
Any questions?
Let me just show
you now, and it may
help you to go through
the previous derivation,
let me know introduce what I
did before, the normal modes,
and then show you
how the energy looks
like defined in normal modes.
So we have these
normal mode variables,
which are defined as a
superposition of A and A dot.
And I'm not telling you
here with all the indices
whether it's the polarization
component, the k component.
I just want to tell
you the structure.
The normal mode is a
superposition of A dot and A.
And with that, the energy
of the electromagnetic field
can be written--
well, we always have
to sum over Fourier components.
We always have to sum
over the polarization.
But then we have something
which is very, very simple
and intuitive.
It's just the square of alpha
with the correct polarization,
the pre-factor is
h bar omega over 2.
It looks like quantum mechanics,
h bar omega times A dagger
A plus 1/2, but this
is purely classical.
There is no quantization,
there is no operator.
We've simply defined
something new, namely alpha
in terms of the
vector potential.
In that sense, if you're going
to go back to the derivation,
the alphas are nothing else
than some elaborate combination
of the transverse electric
and magnetic field.
Colin?
AUDIENCE: Where does
the h bar come in?
Is that the
coefficient of alpha?
PROFESSOR: h bar
only enters through
the constant in the definition
of the normal mode parameter.
So actually, I have
introduced h bar
by choosing this parameter
wisely in such a way
that it connects with
quantum mechanics.
But it's a completely
arbitrary introduction here.
I could have said h bar to 1.
I hope you enjoyed,
or at least did not
dislike this excursion
into classical physics.
We have now two
equations for describing
the energy of a
harmonic oscillator.
So both of these equations look
like a harmonic oscillator,
but if something looks
it is a harmonic oscillator.
And I think I should
always remind you
that so far, everything
has been purely classical.
And also, let me write down
that h bar enters solely
through the constant in the
definition of the normal mode
parameter, alpha.
If you want to
know more about it,
there is a second reference.
I will actually show you the
cover page in a few moments.
But there is a second book
by Claude Cohen-Tannoudji
and collaborators, not
Atom-Photon Interaction,
but called Photons and Atoms.
It's a whole book on
rigorously defining QED.
So a whole book has been
written about the subject
of this lecture, and on page 27,
you can read more about that.
So enough of classical physics.
All we have done so far--
I'm sorry for repeating it,
but I think I can't repeat
it too often with so many
complicated equations on the
screen-- all we have done so
far is we have rewritten
Maxwell's equations.
We have rewritten Maxwell's
equations in Fourier space,
with the vector potential,
eventually with normal modes.
That's all we have done.
But now what we
are doing is we do
the step in quantum mechanics
which you have already
seen a few times, and this
is you have written equations
in such a way that they look
like harmonic oscillators,
and then you postulate that
the classical quantities become
operators.
The transverse vector potential
and the conjugate canonical
momentum fulfill
now commutators,
and we use those commutators
to define them as operators.
Now, it looks particularly
easy when we use normal mode
operators because the
normal mode operators
after quantization become
our a's and a daggers.
That was one of the things
I wanted to show you,
that you can go through
everything introducing
classical normal modes,
and then the normal modes
turns into operators, and
now we have all your creation
and annihilation operators.
In other words, quantization
cannot be rigorously proven.
I mean, you cannot prove quantum
theory from first principles.
You can have a
mathematical framework
and check it against nature.
What we have done here is to
formulate the quantum theory.
At this point, we've
made a postulate
that we have operators which
fulfill a commutation relation.
And it is now your
choice if you want
to formulate postulate
the commutator
for the transverse
vector potential
and its conjugate momentum,
or if you immediately
want to jump at
the normal modes,
and that would mean you have the
commutator for a and a dagger.
We are almost done with that.
We started with the
electromagnetic fields.
We went through
transverse fields, vector
potential, normal
modes, now we quantize.
But now all the equations, all
the substitutions we have made,
we can go backward.
Therefore, we can now
express the transverse vector
potential, the electric
and the magnetic field,
by the normal
modes, or that would
mean in quantum mechanics,
after quantization, we
can express them by
the a's and a daggers,
and this is how we define
the operator of the electric,
the magnetic field, and
the vector potential.
So now, our fully
quantized theory
has operators, a of a
dagger, or if you want now,
the first defined operators
of vector potential, electric
and magnetic field.
And just to remind you,
since atomic physics is
between fields and
particles, we have
exactly the standard definition
of the particle operators.
Each particle is described by
its momentum and its position.
So with that, we
have our Hamiltonian,
and a lot of what we
discuss in this course
are understanding
this Hamiltonian,
understanding its
solution, understanding
what is the physics
described by that.
So this Hamiltonian, this
is the kinetic energy.
The canonical momentum
minus the vector potential
is the mechanical velocity.
This is kinetic energy.
And we have separated the energy
of the electromagnetic field
into the Coulomb energy,
which is written again here,
and the radiation field.
There is now one
more term which we
need later on, which
is this one here.
And at this point, I would say--
I'm just heuristically adding
it by hand-- classical
we don't have spin,
but our particles have spin,
and now we need [INAUDIBLE]
coupling, how does
the spin couple
to the rest of the world?
Well, the spin, if you
multiply it with the g factor,
the Bohr magneton has
a magnetic moment,
and what we simply
add here is mu dot p,
be the interaction of
the magnetic moment
with the magnetic field.
So in that sense, we have
been classical all the way.
Now at the end we
said, we need the spin.
Let's put it on by simply
taking an interaction, which
is mu dot p.
If you don't like
that because I try
to be very fundamental today
and go from first principles,
for electrons, you
can get that by taking
the non-relativistic unit
of the Dirac equation.
So if you have
electrons, you can
start with the Dirac equation
and do the Pauli approximation,
which is the non-relativistic
limit of the Dirac equation.
Any questions?
So these are all the
terms in the Hamiltonian.
I mentioned, but I
don't want to dwell on,
that the Coulomb energy has
to be separated into a Coulomb
self energy and an
interaction energy
between the charged
particles, but all of that
becomes just one term
in our Hamiltonian.
This is the atomic structure.
When we assume that
atoms have energy levels,
all the energy is
included in that,
so we will not discuss any
further the Coulomb energy.
We will simply assume we have
an atom which has certain energy
levels, and that includes
all the Coulomb terms.
But we will talk a lot
about the Hamiltonian
for the radiation field.
The Hamiltonian for
the radiation field
can be conveniently
written in a and a dagger,
but I have a few equations
up there I rigorously
defined for you operators E and
B in terms of a and a daggers,
and those two equations
are identical.
So this looks very quantum,
this looks very classical,
but if you interpret the
electric and magnetic field
as operators, we have
identical equations
for the Hamiltonian of
the radiation field.
What we want to study
are interactions
between light and atoms,
and of course, this
comes from the vector potential.
And in particular,
when we square it out,
the canonical momentum of
the atoms times the vector
potential has this
cross term, p dot a.
So let me know just
take this Hamiltonian
and write it in the way how we
will need it for this course.
We want to take the Hamiltonian,
and I will often refer to that.
We want to take the
Hamiltonian and split it
into three parts, the
atoms, the radiation
field, and the interaction
between the two.
The Hamiltonian for the
particles, H subscript P,
has the momentum
squared, and it has
the part of the electromagnetic
fields which are longitudinal,
the energy of which can
be described by a Coulomb
integral.
We have already discussed
the radiation field.
The radiation field
was nothing else
than h bar omega, a
dagger a, but the new part
which we need now is
the interaction term.
I want to show you
now, or remind you
by just summarizing the term,
that the interaction part has
actually three different terms.
The first one is the cross
term between p and A.
The second one, when we had
p minus A and squared it,
is the A squared term.
And the third one
is the interaction
of the spin with the magnetic
component of the radiation
field.
This is the mu
dot B interaction.
I don't think it's an
exaggeration when I tell you
that with those
three equations, you
can understand all
of atomic physics.
This term here that's
important is second order
in A, which of
course also means it
will be very important for
very strong laser palaces,
but there's more to
be said about it.
If you're interested
in this subject,
and I couldn't do
full justice to it,
you may want to look at
this book from Claude
Cohen-Tannoudji, Jacques
Dupont-Roc, and Gilbert
Grynberg about
photons and atoms.
The whole book is
dedicated how to describe
the interaction of atoms
with electromagnetic fields.
In this book, they go
through different ways
of formulating the
electromagnetic field
classically.
They use Lagrangian formalism
for the electromagnetic field
and show the Euler-Lagrange
equation or Maxwell's equation.
There are lots of
different approaches,
and also, one can
say what we did
here, which is the
simplest way of describing
light-atom interaction,
will work in the Coulomb
gauge, which is not the gauge
you would choose when you want
to describe
relativistic physics.
There is the other gauge,
the Lawrence gauge.
It makes the field quantization
much more difficult,
but when you ever wondered,
why is the quantization done
in the way I did, and you think
something I did was arbitrary--
why did I pick
the Coulomb gauge?
Read this book.
There are hundreds of pages
which explain it to you.
And I'm not joking here,
it's wonderful reading.
I got the book just
looked up a few things
and I almost got hooked on
it and read more and more.
It's a fascinating story how
deeply people have thought
about how to describe
this aspect of the course
and how profound
the thoughts are.
What this book will
emphasize-- and this
is what I want to
tell you in closing
about the quantization of
the electromagnetic field--
is the following.
We were really working hard
with classical field equations
to describe the electromagnetic
field classically by completely
eliminating redundant variables.
We started with six components
of the electric and magnetic
field and reduced it
to two components,
the two components of the
transverse vector potentials.
And as those masters
say, as a result,
the field can be quantized
with a great economy
in the formalism.
If you want to have more
symmetric formulations, where
you don't eliminate the
variables using the Coulomb
gauge, the problem is
you have variables,
which are not independent.
And now I think if
you quantize, you
have to formulate
auxiliary conditions
between the not
independent operators.
Aesthetically, it
may be pleasing
because the approach
is more symmetric,
but mathematically,
it's much more involved.
Anyway, if you're
interested, this book
has a wonderful discussion
on the different ways how
you can approach
interactions of atoms
with electromagnetic fields.
I hope nobody has a
question about that,
because I'm not able to explain
to you much more than that.
Anyway, questions?
We have derived from first
principles the Hamiltonian,
and the result is
something many of you
are already familiar with.
Let me now spend the
next 10 or 15 minutes
on what is called the
dipole approximation
and the dipole Hamiltonian.
We are talking know about
one further expansion
of our expressions, and this
is the multipole expansion.
Let me first give you the
simple derivation, which
you may have seen,
but then you can
appreciate the
rigorous derivation.
Either directly or through
the vector potential,
we have formulated
our theory in terms
of the electric
and magnetic field
as a function of position.
But what we now want to
exploit is that atoms are tiny,
and usually, the electric
or magnetic field
is not changing over the
extent of an atom or molecule.
In other words,
what I'm telling you
is the relevant frequencies,
the relevant components
of the electric
and magnetic fields
will, of course,
be the components
which are in resonance with
the atoms and molecules.
What I'm telling you is that
in many, many situations,
the wavelengths of
the relevant modes
of the electromagnetic
field are much, much longer
than the size of an atom.
So therefore, if we pinpoint
our atom at the origin,
we may be able to neglect
the spatial dependence
of the electromagnetic
fields and replace it
by electric and magnetic
fields at the origin.
Or, if you want to go higher
in a Taylor expansion,
we use gradients of it.
We've talked more
about that, actually,
in 8.421, when we talked
about multipole transitions,
but here I want to only focus
on the lowest order, which
is called the electric
dipole approximation,
because this is the most
important case which
is used in atomic physics.
So for the electric
dipole approximation,
we make actually
several assumptions.
One is we neglect the quadratic
term, the a squared term.
And now if you look
at the A dot p term,
and we are looking for
matrix elements between two
atomic levels, we expand
the vector potential
into plain waves.
Well, it's called the
electric dipole approximation,
so maybe we want
to express things
by the electric field, which
is the derivative of the vector
potential.
So with that, we have
now described things
by the electric field.
And what is needed now is if
we assume that kr equals 0,
or r over lambda is
very, very small,
the exponential, the plain wave
vector, is approximated by 1,
and we are simply left in the
electric dipole approximation
with the a element of
the momentum operator.
We can simplify it further by
writing the momentum operator
as the commutator
between the position
operator and the Hamiltonian.
If you take the commutator
between r or x and p squared,
you'd simply get
p and p factors,
so that's what we are using.
And now the matrix
element becomes-- so what
we have here now is rH
minus Hr, but H acting on 1,
because 1 is an eigenstate,
gives the energy, E1.
And for the flipped
part, we have Hr,
and now H acting on state
two gives us the energy, E2.
So therefore, by taking care
of the Hamiltonian, which
gives us, depending on which
side H appears, E1 or E2,
we have reduced it to now
a position matrix element.
And what we have
here is, of course,
the transition frequency
between the levels one and two.
I know you have seen it, but if
I can derive it in two minutes,
it's maybe worth the exercise.
What I've shown you is that
the momentum matrix element
can be replaced by the position
matrix element multiplied
by the resonance frequency.
But now we want to
put things together,
and what I want to
point out for you
is that we have an
omega here, which
is the frequency of the
electromagnetic field,
and we have an omega 12 here,
which is the transition energy.
So therefore, if
I put it together,
I started with a p
dot a Hamiltonian,
but the p matrix element
became an r matrix element.
The a was expressed
by the electric field.
So therefore, we have
now the electric field
times the position
matrix element,
or the dipole matrix
element, if you
multiply the position of the
electron with the charge two.
But in addition, we
have this prefactor.
So this becomes the
dipole Hamiltonian
E dot d when we replace
that by 1, assuming
that we are interested anyway
only in interactions with atoms
where the radiation
field is near resonance.
So it seems that we have
actually made three assumptions
to derive the electric
dipole approximation.
One was the long
wavelengths approximation.
The second one was that
we are near resonance,
and the third one was that we
neglected the quadratic term
in the light-atom interaction.
There are often people who
are wondering about it.
When I said we are
only interested when
the atoms interact with
electromagnetic radiation
near resonance, that's
OK, but atomic physics
is the area of physics
with the highest precision.
We can make measurements with
10 to the minus 16 and 10
to the minus 17 precision.
So therefore, if you have an
electromagnetic field which
resonates with atoms--
the typical frequency
of visible light is
10 to the 14 Hertz--
and you're just one megahertz
away from the resonance,
it's 10 to the minus 8.
So the question is, would
we observe a correction
to the dipole approximation if
omega 12 is not exactly omega?
Well, the answer is no because,
as I want to show you now
in the next few minutes,
and this is also
the end of our flyover
over the appendix
of atom-photon interaction,
the last two assumptions
are not really necessary.
In other words, we go back
to atom-photon interaction,
to this long appendix on
the derivation of the QED
Hamiltonian.
We go back to our
fundamental Hamiltonian,
and we want to do
one approximation
and this is the only
approximation which is needed.
It is the dipole
approximation, and that
means that the vector
potential-- of course, we
only need the transverse part
of it-- is replaced by its value
at the origin.
That's the only approximation.
So here is our Hamiltonian
in its full beauty,
and the only thing we have
done is we've put in the origin
here.
For later convenience, we
introduce the dipole operator,
which is the position
operator of particle
alpha times the charge
of particle alpha.
And then we do simply
a transformation.
So this is a unitary
transformation,
and we transform from the
original Hamiltonian, which
includes the p dot a term
and the a squared term
to a transformed
Hamiltonian, H prime.
And this transformed Hamiltonian
has now the electric dipole
approximation.
It's sort of written in
polarization Fourier space,
but this is the electric field,
and a, a dagger gives position.
I'm sorry.
These are normal modes.
It's a dipole operator
times the electric field,
and the A squared
term has disappeared.
So after the transformation,
we have no quadratic term,
and all we are left is
this is nothing else
than d dot e, the
dipole interaction.
And there is no prefactor
omega 12 over omega.
This is a rigorous
unitary transformation
to another basis.
In full disclosure, it
involves a dipolar self energy,
which is sort of
a constant energy.
And if you look at the
transformed velocities,
the transformed
velocities v prime are now
identical to the original
canonical momentum.
So after that, what was
the canonical momentum
in the original
Hamiltonian, H, becomes
now velocity times mass.
So p becomes now the
mechanical momentum.
And therefore, p squared
is the kinetic energy.
Anyway, I think
this is important
that we have this much
more rigorous deviation
of the dipole approximation.
I don't want to go through that.
I just want to make
sure you have seen it.
If you want to do it
really rigorously,
then you have to distinguish
between the electric field
d and E. So you have
an electric field here,
and here you have
the polarization.
It's pretty much the same
as in classical e and m.
At the end of the day, we have
now, for the prime operator,
for the Hamiltonian after
the canonical transformation,
after the unitary
transformation,
the only interaction
term which remains
is the electric dipole
interaction between the dipole
and this field d, but this
field d prime corresponds
to the original a
transverse electric field.
I'm not going to explain
the difference between E,
E prime, d, and d prime.
It can be done rigorously.
But the take home message
is-- and with that, I
want to conclude-- that
for most of this course,
the interaction of the
electromagnetic field
with our atoms is
described by this term.
We take the transverse
electric field.
This is our radiation
field, and it
couples to the operator of
the atomic dipole moment.
I hope you got the
take home message
that whenever you have
any doubts about any part
of this deviation, or if you
have any doubts whether it's
rigorous or not,
you know now where
to look it up and learn
everything about it.
Any questions?
OK, then that's it.
We'll probably post the first
homework assignment tomorrow--
I will meet with the TAs-- and
it will be due in about a week,
but you will see all
of that on the website
and hear from me on Wednesday.
Have a good afternoon.